einige wochen sind vergangen ich mit
freunden und jetzt habe ich heute
endlich mal wieder begrüßen zu einer
neuen episode luke am 1
schwarzer humor ist wie klopapier hat
nicht jeder und da bin ich noch schüler
direkt raus früher hände hoch oder ich
schieße heute hände hoch oder ich
schieße
euch eigentlich felix aus dem mathebuch
kauft 40 rollen klopapier 2015 hh werk
auf wirte 40 rollen klopapier 2020 nur
in wie handeln alle luca - heute von der
aktuellen situation dieser moment wenn
alle schüler frei kriegen du aber mit
der schule fertig bist ja darüber habe
ich mich auch schon mit sandra in
unserem sinne tatsächlich mittlerweile
täglich erscheinenden podcast dick und
doof erhalten jetzt gerade das übrigens
auch wieder eine neue folge online
gegangen auf spotify apple podcast lisa
und ich keine luft mehr in meiner schule
hätte für ein meteorit einschlagen
können die hätten das ding nicht
zugemacht und jetzt hat jeder ferien und
ja ich muss das wort zensieren weil man
video sonst nicht werbe freundlich wird
februar ich sitze zu hause märz ich
sitze zu hause und bin ein vorbild das
ist die wahrheit was ist grün und sagt
immer das ist die wahrheit
witzig seid ihr heute mal wieder an alle
kinder die mein haus an halloween mit
klopapier beworfen haben
danke ja meine lieben freunde mein haus
wird leider nie mit klopapier beworfen
ich habe kein haus dieser moment wenn
deine fledermaus suppe so gut schmeckt
das drei monate später jeder darüber
redet dann haben wir heute hier
irgendwie wirklich nur solche aktuellen
- zur aktuellen situation
sprachen lernen da der trend 2009/10
airports trend 2020 die infektionswelle
ab
das einzig positive am heutigen tag war
mein kopf
com
[Musik]
ja quarantäne - kamera auch ein paar
unter anderem auch das hier tag 14 in
quarantäne meine mama kannst du bitte
aufhören deine schwester zu ärgern bitte
ich warum kriege ich sonst hausarrest
es fühlt sich gerade wirklich an als
hätte angela merkel uns allen einfach
hauses gegeben tag 15 in quarantäne es
ist 14.30 und ich mache mir bereits die
siebte mahlzeit heute das ist leider
auch war ich werde extrem dick gerade
also nicht dick aber ich nehme zu ich
mache auch sport gerade und ich alles in
serie doch was ich wirklich mal kurz
sagen wollte ist ich finde wir sollten
das ganz mal ein bisschen positiver
sehen und ein bisschen optimistischer
sein
ja natürlich ist die situation gerade
ein bisschen blöd wir würden alle gern
die bei das tolle frühlings zu schneiden
s
neid ist aber auch egal dass es ist es
quarantäne tag 16 ich will mir
mittlerweile nicht mehr ganz sicher ob
ich hunger habe oder ist einfach nur die
langeweile ist nein ganz kurz reald
hockey eben es schneit
nee ich will dass wir alle ein bisschen
optimistischer sind
ich war grade im supermarkt und es war
alles voll alles alle nudeln da ein
kompletter reißt da man kann so viel
schaffen gerade im haushalt man kann so
viel lernen sich weiterbilden und ich
weiß ihr habt alles wahrscheinlich schon
extrem viele hausaufgaben oft aber guten
arbeit mit diesem ihm hier und zwar mein
tag 17 in quarantäne meinen doktor
gestern zu mir sie sollten abnehmen
nehmen sie am besten ein fahrrad und
halbieren sie die kohlenhydrate ich
doppelpunkt nun im fall helga und jetzt
würde ich sagen kommen wir auch zu
normalen - und zwar dieser moment wenn
dein sitznachbar mit ihr redet und tue
dafür angeschrieben wird
ich will es nicht sagen
ich sage es noch nicht aber ich weiß was
ich jetzt sagen würde lockruf erlassen
oder c 25 karten ich das ist süß ist süß
und lustig das ist sehr schön dass jetzt
das nächste mal werden lehrer nicht in
der lage ist alle fächer zu unterrichten
warum erwartet man dann von schülern
alles zu können
das ist dass das ist es auch das was ich
gerade sagen wollte das was man isst
dass dieser moment wenn du ins bett
gehen willst sie aber noch einfällt dass
die hausaufgaben machen muss
[Applaus]
ja
schlimmste überhaupt
und ich mache mir ist es gerade ehrlich
gesagt aus also klar ich muss jetzt
nicht wenn ich ins bett gehe dass man
dann auffällt dass ich noch hausaufgaben
machen muss dass muss ich halt nicht
mehr geld nicht mehr in die schule aber
ich finds auch so schlimm man legt sich
ins bett man dazu zähne geputzt und ist
so fertig liegt im bett so voll schön
dann merkt man aber verdammt ich hab
kein handy ladekabel oder irgendwie
sondern apple-mitarbeiter dich prangt
hat er dich wortwörtlich veräppelt okay
wir haben neuen tiefpunkt ein tag oder
schokolade und der bauch ist immer noch
da ich habe mir schon gedacht dass es
nichts daran liegen kann ja ich weiß
nicht warum ich diese luca - videos
machen jetzt gar nicht so langweilig
aber warum sind in einer packung reis
12.000 278 km/h drin und in der anderen
nur zwölf 1256 in der zeit auf ich auch
wieder nicht direkt in die mitte sondern
direkten weg von den ganzen leuten
es ist die wahrheit
warum ist das eigentlich so ein ruhiger
geworden warum sage ich überhaupt die
ganze zeit die wahrheit ist es ja ich
meine es ist auch die wahrheit mit
hunger einkaufen unbezahlbar das o mein
gott das war ich heute morgen im
supermarkt ich hab mir halt auch so
gedacht wow ich sehe dass jeder
irgendwie gerade hamsterkäufe macht und
so weiter und so fort ich will da nicht
mitziehen aber ich kaufe jetzt einmal
ein bisschen mehr ein weil ich hatte
heute morgen halt richtig hunger mit
nudeln gekauft zucchini tomaten zwiebeln
kartoffeln reis spülmaschinen tabs
dressing
235 euro wie kann die ganz eigenwillige
aus dem brook lehrer doppelpunkt nicht
direkt aus der quelle kopieren wikipedia
doppelpunkt er starb 1957 ich glaube von
1957 startete das hundertprozentig ich
bei meiner bachelorarbeit gewesen wie
finde ich meinen neuen pop schutz sie
habe ich hier ein bisschen nackig der
ton anders wenn ich jetzt einen spiegel
kann man nur gebraucht kaufen das ist
die wahrheit
das ich hab schon wieder gesagt aber es
ist die wahrheit manche leute sind die
pizza margarita sie haben einfach nichts
drauf das ist das ist dass das ist kann
man auf auf mich nicht weil ich bin
jetzt ich bin hastig auf der suche nach
motivation zum lernen
irgendwie
finde ich die - halt witzig auf der
anderen seite
denke ich mir aber auch so wir sind
langsam und am erdkern vom niveau habt
ihr schon mal ein buch gelesen was euch
richtig zum weinen gebracht hat nein
dann schlagt mein mathebuch auf mein
gott ich habe matte gehasst aber noch
mal abstimmen
mir ist so langweilig halte ich wenig
dass diese quarantänezeit aufhört sandra
doppelpunkt was ist deine lieblingsfarbe
luca doppelpunkt weiß nichts esa
doppelpunkt welche dank der warmen um
die ecke gebracht
[Musik]
diese quarantäne macht meinen kompletten
kopf kaputt lehrer doppelt und ich habe
die nase voll von eurem gequatsche
dahinten luca dafür brauchen sie ein
taschentuch hammerschmiede zwei ebenen
kluge antwort wegen nase voll
taschentuch
das hier ist zwar kein richtiges team
aber halt einfach ein tolles
unbearbeitetes foto von mir mit schuhen
ja falls noch kein abonnent von meinem
kann einseitig gern auf abonnieren in
dem video ist kostenlos kann ich euch
wärmstens empfehlen hier kriegt mit den
besten content während der
quarantänezeit täglich lade ich hoch zu
bauen haben ja das ist das nächste wie
manche menschen lassen sich leicht
manipulieren ließ es nochmal und hier
menschen lassen sie online ganz kurze
info
ich reagiere live auf diesem ins netz
ich bin auf instagram unterwegs schaue
auf was sich markiert werde
und reagieren da live drauf
und du
user userin lovely
welchen tee sollte man besser nicht
trinken tnt ist es wieder von der
gleichen userin und la villette von
daher
[Musik]
big lots doppelpunkt am erster sechsten
kommt ein paar jecken kissen in den
lukas schlug ru feiertag ist das jetzt
ein bild wo ich wann oder wo ich mich
vorher kommt es am ersten sechs lukac
die produktion in italien das war sonst
immer gut wegen der qualität der
produkte aber irgendwie ist es jetzt
gerade hat sie negativen beigeschmack
als verstand jetzt kommt es am ersten
sechs minuten schoss aber adler und
warum seid ihr noch hier
wenn ihr noch da seid dann klickt alter
auf den smiley wenn ihr noch keiner zeit
habe ich schon gesagt dass ich mich auch
hier sollte
und zwar in den blick nehmen
könnt ihr den smiley klicken wenn ihr
schon allein zeit könnt ihr ja oft das
video da da klicken das ein altes luca -
video aber wir können doch einfach auf
den smiley klicken wenn ihr halt noch
kein abonnent sein wer halt extrem